(scraping)
(peaceful music)
- I really enjoy working with fish skin.
It's something that feels right.
Because I spend so much
time outside, I am inspired
by this huge landscape that Alaska has.
I tend to gravitate towards
those materials that mimic
the natural beauty that
I'm used to seeing.
(contemplative music)
(wings flapping)
My name is Joel Isaak.
I am a Dena'ina Athabaskan
Alaska native artist, and I work
a lot with living materials
like fish skin, or wood.
For thousands of years, people
in Alaska have been fishing,
and only taking what you need
really is a traditional way
of working with fish.
I use fish skin to create many
different types of objects.
I've made high heels for
models; I've made dresses;
I've made a halibut skin
motorcycle jacket; I make masks.
It's stronger per
thickness than mammal hide,
and that gives it more strength
for stretching and pulling.
It does expand and contract,
and you can have kind of
a relationship with it.
Most the fish skin that I use, I catch.
And all the fish skin that I
use, I clean, and I process,
and I tan myself.
One of the traditional
methods is by fish eggs,
and that takes three days
of soaking the fish skins,
and then they need to be hand-softened,
which is a very laborous process.
(scraping)
The land has been very
formative for the type of work
that I create, and fish skin, for me,
is a very sustainable practice.
It's a living material, and
I have a connection to it.
It's been part of my whole entire life,
being here at the beach.
That's part of what makes me
Dena'ina is that interaction
living with salmon and
being around the land.